الى اين تسير الحرب في اوكرانيا التطورات
باتت تتارجح بين نقيضين دعوه للتفاوض من
هنا وتصعد ميداني متواصل من هناك ما يجعل
التكهن بمسارها
امر اخر التطورات ما كشفت عنه مجله نيوزيك
الامريكيه التي قالت ان هناك مسار عسكريا
جديدا تخطط روسيا لتنفيذه خلال الفتره
المقبله في اوكرانيا مجله نيوزويك
الامريكيه نقلت عن معهد دراسه الحرب في
واشنطن تقارير تفيد بان موسكو تضع اللمسات
الاخيره على هذا المسار الذي وصفته
بالاكثر خطوه
التقرير اكد هذه المره النابله روسيا
ستكون محطه مهمه في هذا المسار العسكري
الجديد فاضافت المجله ان زياده عدد القوات
الروسيه في بيلاروسيا هو جزء من خطه
الكريمه لتجديد غزو اوكرانيا وذكر المعهد
ان الرئيس البيلاروسيا الكسندر لوكيشنكو
اختبر الاستعداد القتالي لقوه بلاده ما
يثير شكوكا حول امكانيه مشاركه بين روسيا
مباشره في الحرب
ميدانيا يبدو ان الامور تسير نحو صدمات
اضافيه في ظل المسارات العسكريه الجديده
لكن هذا التطور لا يلغي الحل الديبلوماسيه
الذي عاد ليطفوا الى السطح مجددا الرئيس
روسي قال ان بلاده مستحده للتفاوض مع كل
اطراف الصراع الاوكراني حلول مقبوله وتابع
بوتان ان الامر يعود الاكياب وحلفائها في
موسكو لا ترفض التفاوض لكن هم من يرفضون
على احد
كيف لم تتاخر في الرد على تصريحات الرئيس
الروسيه وجاء ذلك على لسان ميخائيل فضل
يكى مستشار الرئيس الاوكراني الذي اتهم
موسكو بالتنصل من المسؤوليه حيث دعى عبد
حسابه على تويتر الى العوده الى ارض
الواقع ملتهما روسيا بعدم الرغبه في
التفاوض ان دعواتها غير جديه
بالحديث عن الحلول المقبوله كانت موسكو قد
المحت في الكثير من المناسبات الى شروط من
اجل قبول التفاوض مع كلاب وحلفائها وتتلخص
فيه التوقف عن داخل اسلحه والاموال للجيش
الاوكراني الاعتراف بالمناطق التي ضمتها
روسيا بعد العمليه العسكريه استئناف
الحوار على اساس المتكافئ دون اجبار روسيا
على تقديم تناسلات
[موسيقى]